What happened,
the academy has,
has always leaned left in the 20th
century,
but leaning isn't the problem.
So people think,
oh,
viewpoint diversity we need,
we need everybody.
We need Nazis.
We need.
No,
we don't need everybody.
What we need is no orthodoxy.
That's what's fatal orthodoxy.
So if you have a,
if you have a field like sociology or
social psychology in which it's two or
three to one left to right,
that's totally fine with me.
That's totally fine because if someone
makes some claim that's just like
ideologically blind,
someone will say,
uh,
you know,
common sense,
other evidence that you've missed and
then the system works.
But what I learned when I started down
this road in 2011,
I gave a talk at the big conference with
social psychologists.
I gave a talk about this problem that
we're losing our diversity,
that I could only find one conservative
in the entire field.
And I gave a talk on this.
Um,
and um,
um,
and so what I've learned since then is
that the ratio in psychology was between
two to one and four to one left,
right?
All the way up to the early nineties,
we've gathered together all of the
studies we could find.
So all the up to the early nineties,
it's only three or four to one left to
right,
which would be okay.
Um,
but then between 1995 or four and 2010,
it goes to a 14 to one.
Do you have any idea why and why that
time?
Yes.
So,
um,
so you get the same story whether you
look at Republican,
Democrat ratios or liberal conservative
there,
they tell the same story.
So the two of the big things going on
there are one is that the greatest
generation which had a lot of
Republicans,
um,
so a lot of men go off to World War II.
They are there on the Gi bill.
They entered the academy in the 19
fifties.
A lot of them are conservative or
Republican and so you have a lot of
them,
but in the sixties and seventies,
one of the main reasons to go to Grad
school and the social sciences is either
a to stay in school to escape the
Vietnam war draft or be to fight for
social justice and against racism.
So in sociology and psychology in
particular and political science maybe
I'm not sure.
You get a huge influx of left leaning
people who are there to pursue social
justice so you know the motives are fine
and if it was balanced to be totally
fine,
but as you get these young junior people
on the left come in in the seventies and
eighties and then you get the older
people that are more politically
balanced,
retiring of the eighties and nineties.
By the time you get to the late nineties
it's all baby boomers and so do you get
a.
You get a positive feedback loop
developing their.
Like you said,
if it's like three to one,
it's okay,
but maybe when it hits four to one it
goes to like 20 to one.
Then you stick.
Exactly.
So then,
so then you start getting hostile
climate.
So I wrote a review paper on this with
a,
with Joe Duarte and Phil and lead Justin
Jarrett,
Crawford,
um,
and um,
and we,
uh,
we reviewed everything that we could
find and we concluded that most of
what's going on is self selection.
That is people on the left are more open
to experience.
They're always going to get self
selection.
But then there's really good evidence
that there's also hostile climate.
I mean,
it's undeniable now that if you are not
on the left in a Grad program,
there's just constant little subtle or
not so subtle reminders that you don't
belong.
And in the academy we're all about
saying,
Hey,
if there are subtle hints here and
there,
you can't succeed.
Right?
I mean,
that's what we do for a living is when
we say that little things will stop
people.
Um,
well,
little things are put in the way of
anyone who doesn't fit politically.
Uh,
and so you do get hostile climate,
you do get over discrimination.
There's evidence of that.
And then there is also,
it is part of the story here that what
it means to be a conservative in the
nineties and especially 2000 has
changed.
So,
um,
it is true that you know,
that,
that the,
the conservative,
we're not in any way anti-science,
um,
until much more recent times.
Now actually both sides are anti-science
about different sciences.
But I'm in America,
the right wing,
the Republican Party has,
it's controversial,
but I do believe that the polarization
starts with the right moving further
out.
So what it means to be conservative to
the anti anti evolutionary,
which is actually what's happening on
the left now to exactly.
That's.
Yeah.
So,
well as modern laptop to Bret Weinstein
the other day.
And you know,
he,
one of his claims is that evolutionary
biology has something in it to offend
everyone.
So it's a,
it's a science that's very likely to be
targeted by extremists.
You also brought up something that
actually touches on the site on the
difficult problem of how it is that you
might define someone who is
ideologically possessed,
let's say,
or ideologically rigid,
because the idea was that you can make a
valid case for the utility of free
information flow and the free flow of
people that would go along with that and
you could make a good case for the
danger of that.
And so the idea might be that if you're
only making a case for the danger of
that,
then you're tilted too far to the right.
And if you're only making a case for the
utility of that,
then you're tilted too far to the left.
Exactly.
That's right.
And so we can look at immigration as a
nice example.
There was a recent essay in the
Atlantic,
I think it was by Peter Beinart,
where he,
um,
he reviews.
He had started with a lot of quotes that
are pretty nuanced positions about
immigration from Barack Obama.
Paul Krugman,
a bunch of other people on the left who
used to be able to say,
on the one hand,
you know,
compassion,
economic,
on the other hand,
you know,
we have to have a legal process and
there's a threat to low wage workers,
so people on the left,
you still have to talk about immigration
and talk about the pros and cons,
pluses and minuses,
but beinart shows how in the last four
or five years you can't if you so much
as suggest that will maybe immigration
is a net good,
but it might have some deleterious
effects on certain classes of of low
wage American workers.
You could get in big trouble,
right?
Because that's instantly prejudicial
because immigration has become a sacred
topic.
So this is the key thing that I want
everyone to keep in mind.
We are fundamentally religious creatures
were built for religion and it's a great
achievement to create a scientific
establishment and an academic
establishment that keeps that way of
thinking out.
Scientific thinking is not natural
thinking.
Religious thinking is natural thinking
and what's happening to us in the last
few years especially is a flooding in of
religious thinking and so let's get a
bunch of social scientists talk about
immigration.
What are they going to do?
Look at the data,
way up.
The pluses and minuses.
No,
they're going to.
Many of them feel they're on a team and
that team is fighting the right.
The right is anti-immigrant.
It includes racist elements there for
that justifies us in being pro.
Immigration and social sciences are
always.
There's always ambiguity.
There's always conflicting stories,
multiple causal factors.
Is that always in the social science
study?
That's right.
So [inaudible] point was that the left
used to be able to think straight about
immigration.
Clearly it had a,
you know,
it was generally pro immigration,
but it used to be able to think
straight,
but in the last few years a religious
orthodox mindset has overtaken it.
Okay.
So we might as well also pointed out
that it's a primordial religious
mindset,
right?
Because I mean there are definitely
Christian or Jewish,
I mean ancient tribal,
small scale,
lots of gods.
Right,
right.
Well,
so then one of the things that you might
suggest is that when you throw out a
sophisticated religious structure in
unsophisticated religious structure
comes in to fill the gap.
I do.
So that's true.
That's definitely worth thinking about.
So that's right.
The thing with religions,
we have to clarify,
fundamentalism is the problem,
not religion.
And so if you close tribalism,
that's right.
If you get a fundamentalist,
you know,
I'm happy to say,
and if you have people applying to a
Grad program in psychology and I find
out that they're Christian,
that's fine.
There's no problem.
But if they're fundamentalist Christian,
I would think,
well let's say let's say it's not
psychologists,
it's a geology.
So somewhat applies to a geology
program.
There are fundamentalists,
young,
earth creationist.
Are you gonna admit them?
No,
I don't think you should.
They're not able to do the right kind of
thinking based on what we know to be the
case there.
They're not in the scientific paradigm,
not in the sand type.
That's right.
So,
so if we wouldn't admit a fundamentalist
Christian to a geology program,
why would we admit someone who is just
as fundamentalist about certain moral
and political issues into a sociology
program or into a psychology program if
they come in knowing what the right
answer is,
committed to that right answer,
likely to get angry at anyone who
contravenes that right answer.
Um,
and,
and showing signs of close mindedness.
I don't think they belong in the.
I guess the question is how in the world
do you set up mechanisms to ensure that
you're not swamped by fundamentalists of
any sort?
So those are people who are reducing
everything to a single cause.
It's something like that.
How can you implement a structure that
protects the organization against that
without the structure itself becoming
totalitarian?
Because these things,
these things spin out of control so
fast.
But so,
you know,
I think what we have to realize in the
academy is that we face,
I think we face an existential crisis.
Um,
we rely on an enormous amount of public
goodwill.
We get enormous tax subsidies,
a direct research support and recent
polling shows that while Democrats have
always had a higher opinion of the
universities and Republicans until two
years ago,
everybody thought universities are a
good thing.
They make life better.
So Americans have been very supportive
of higher education.
There have been rising gripes on the
right,
but it's only between 2015 and 2017 that
now republicans go from saying mostly
universities are good things in two
years.
They go way down and say universities
are bad things.
They're making things worse.
Now,
how is this news greeted?
Pundits on the left are saying,
oh,
those republicans are so anti science.
Look how ignorant they are.
They now hate universities.
Come on.
Anybody who's been watching the news,
anybody who's seen the mobs,
the shout downs,
the illiberal behavior,
you know,
the metaphor I use is like,
Americans on the right and left are
really supportive of the military.
We have.
It's one of the few institutions that we
still hold in highest team on both
sides.
And so the Republicans more than
Democrats.
So suppose you had Gallup poll and I,
uh,
showing Republicans liked the military
more than Democrats,
but both really liked it.
Then suddenly in 2015 we started seeing
video from all over military bases and
military academies in which the,
the military leaders are overtly right
wing.
They're there,
they're saying terrible things about
leftists and progressives and the
midshipmen and the cadets and everybody
is mobbing the occasional liberal and to
behaving in a really despicable,
scary and intimidating way.
What do you think the left would now
think about the military?
Obviously support for the military would
plummet and that's what's happening in
America with universities.
We are losing the support of half the
country.
This is unsustainable,
especially in red states where,
you know,
they control the purse strings.
So I think we have a major crisis.
I think we've got to go into crisis mode
and we've got to clean up our act.
So just as we're doing in psychology
with replication project where we
recognize that our methods weren't good
enough and we're doing a crash course,
a thanks to Brian Nosek and others,
the open science project,
we're really trying to improve our game.
Thank God we need to.
I think we have to do the exact same
thing about partisanship and our on our
duty.